[Música]
[Aplausos]
o professor e pesquisador de lá e como
vamos influenciar ou como vamos defender
aquela pessoa que precisa de quem é essa
pessoa que está lá quem é esse eleitor
teve áudio onde agora o que ele faz é
complementar a gente que esse eleitor
quem nós somos
afinal vivemos - nesse sentido nós temos
que fazer algumas reflexões sobre de que
forma eu posso fazer para ajudar no país
a gente compensar como as coisas estão
sei que talvez jogar carga agora o
eleitor a carga para nós mesmos
o que eu posso fazer para ajudar meu
estado o o que eu poderia fazer para
ajudar a minha cidade
vamos fechar mais o meu bairro
a minha rua
as ações locais ou as mudanças locais
normalmente são iniciadas no ano em que
local
nós temos que ter o pensamento sob essa
perspectiva a maneira com a qual nós
podemos interagir com espaços públicos
ficou a política muito mais do que isso
até mesmo para entender o papel do
eleitor pois temos o balde se for mal
disse que a sociedade a oportunidade de
tudo é em nosso trabalho é crítica
nós somos cada vez mais intolerantes
para o outro
nós temos esse senso de agastamento de
até choque
estamos à flor da pele o tempo inteiro e
só os pontos acomodados com as críticas
esse é o grande problema da pós
modernidade em que tudo atua junto às
instituições estão o tempo inteiro sendo
notificadas
aquilo que era estável por aquele preta
gil inteira isso não é mais um mero uma
realidade as gerações novas até as mais
novas
eu já estou com 4 de junho os alunos
universitários tendencialmente terão
cinco seis oito dez empregos ao longo da
sua carreira ao passo que nossos pais
avós pensava em encerrar sua vida e
correr do mesmo lugar isso é o tipo de
percurso idade é um estado de paz
hoje em dia quase está com a difusão com
você buscar cada vez mais novos desafios
diferentes anos
vemos também tempo de pós verdade e
aquilo que eu acho é afinal aperta a
tecla não é isso
olha os terroristas eu estaria aqui
fazer uma belíssima campanha exatamente
esse grau de complexidade das relações
que nós temos que preparar todo mundo se
agora de achar que a terra pode ser
aquilo que não é
ou nós podemos embora nossa visão de
mundo como se isso fosse uma realidade
científica comprovada
esse é o grande problema ninguém começa
com ninguém e as pessoas gostam colocar
a sua visão como se fosse na verdade
vivemos em um egoísta que estamos
pensando nas nossas relações na nossa
roupa o nosso carro do meu o domínio e
nada mais importa nesse sentido cada vez
mais e se esse sentimento egoísta é
aquilo que se reflete num patamar que é
nosso e leitura vídeo nosso eleitor lito
é aquele que está afastado do universo
com a comunidade que ele participa e
quanto mais nosso onze corridas mais
individualista pensamos mas não pensamos
no torneio na sociedade e isso acaba
o governo porque a verdade escola a nós
vivemos é constantemente a medida de
alguns protestos
o brasil teve uma convulsão eu digo que
não foi como um soluço ao gigante
acordou acordo com toldo na sequência
quero mesmo é muito no fundo tudo vai
ser diferente
não escuto esse papo não souber soltou
um pouco mais a escutar algum tempo que
o brasil vai crescer agora quando isso
acontecer a lei ficha limpa vai mudar
enfim sempre esperamos que alguma coisa
venha a acontecer e quase sempre alguém
vai trazer essa mudança pra gente o que
qual é o saldo de nós levamos daqui
tanta mobilização tanto face ativismo
pelos questões e da onde nós estamos e
como nossos números de la à realidade
nacional demonstrando um sentimento de
apatia política o que é a partir daí os
cientistas políticos entendem os surdos
da abstenção eleitoral seja gente não
vai parecer polêmica parece mais 4
branco num conjunto e não vai ser aqui
na quaresma os candidatos a líbia
apareceu a uma melhora da margem para
salvar nossa vida não vai acontecer isso
então isso é esse dado estatístico da
partilha cultural das pessoas que
poderia contar uma cota vai crescendo
eleição após eleição 2010 26% das
pessoas que poderia votar votar o ato
com a última eleição 2016 brasil 32%
abaixo crescer 10% e 10 5% 51 milhões de
brasileiros vão deixar de escolher quem
é o seu presidente tem será que poderia
ser o seu governador
mais restrito senador deputados federais
e estaduais
ou seja é bem possível que essas pessoas
que não votaram seja o maior contingente
populacional daquele que venha a ser
eleito
e aí isso gera um senso de ilegitimidade
tamanho 6%
alguns estudos jurídicos seguinte nós
não víamos naquele então veja o efeito
bumerangue contra nós confiamos mas nós
precisamos é essa agora moderna ela
necessita ter políticos de pessoas que
irão nos representar
qual é o nosso papel
ele é então com isso faz toda a
diferença
quanto mais escuro
futuro - elas participam e quando se
cobra é se essa tabela sobre costa motor
foi através do país com o voto
obrigatório é o verdinho de país com
voto facultativo e roxo
a gente vai ver que é uma coisa mas
quero que o voto obrigatório pode forçar
as pessoas a participar mas a
participação dele só não é sinônimo de
acreditar de sentir se desde uma lei que
as estatísticas quando global sobre
participação pé x bota empregador a
tendência da américa latina de leve se
um crescimento para comparecer das ruas
no brasil o bic de queda comparecemos
mas estamos comparecendo - nós na europa
osce catalisadores canadá
cada vez mais as pessoas não comparecem
às urnas
então essa crise de legitimidade é uma
crise real porque as pessoas não parece
um propósito também não ser
representados nem aí fica um grande
dilema de como vamos sair desse bebê
além do que nós temos várias ameaças à
nossa capacidade cívica eleitoral da
nossa evolução enquanto maturação do
universo político melhor professor que
mais usa calça nova york é induzir
alguém aí ela quer prejudicar as
interferências de ao político econômicas
a gente acha que o brasil está imune a
isso tudo que aconteceu estados unidos
que aconteceu no reino unido possa
inclusive acho que devemos entender que
existem interesses estratégicos
geopolíticos e econômicos a querer
interferir naqueles que irão comandar o
nosso país
além disso tudo nós temos outras
questões o brasil e fazer uma lei das
eleições e 90
7 ele a única lei das eleições
só que aconteceu ali pra frente toda
eleição faz uma alteraçãozinha não me
para buscar mudar e quer fazer com que
as coisas sejam melhores que há anos
ou seja tanto as leis isso não só uma
eleitoral
mas quem foi o que foi o carnaval
empresário sabe quando o espírito tem
que pagar e como as coisas mudam o dia
da ordem minuto tantas leis nega um
sentimento de anomia
ou seja muito quase que nós porque estão
entorpecidos que a gente não acredita em
nada e aí esse sentimento de segurança
com 10 leitos geram essa ensina a fazer
uma melhorada com nós conseguimos hoje
melhores políticos que elegemos há 20
anos a democrática no brasil ainda não é
tão longa
mas eleitorais vidas são realizadas para
garantir que o status quo ou seja quem
está quer ficar e quero tentar
neutralizar aqueles que custou a entrar
nessa seara
isso é muito significativo nessa ordem
são que estamos a experimentar 2018 com
diminuição de tempo de televisão
diminuição do tempo de campanha e
diminuíram a importá lo
o tribunal de justiça cortou o
financiamento de de empresas e porto
apareceu dinheiro que não tinha dinheiro
para financiar a educação saúde e
segurança fala taquara
os políticos fazem concorrência não
almoço de graça e quarto lugares e é
esse fenômeno vai aparecer não gasto é
um passo necessário
nós precisamos investir em democracia
mas neste domingo precisando investido
com qualidade para que esse sucesso lá
com 6% que aqueles que acreditam com o
senhor recebeu algum tipo de melhora e
quanto mais nós não acreditamos mais nós
afastamos não sentimento natural do ser
humano de recurso aquilo que nós não
acreditamos será que ele vai conseguir
inverter esse jogo de cada vez mais
reforçar pelo almoçamos assim uma
interferência excessiva estava nossa
democracia jovem nosso estado é minha do
de lada a gente precisa fazer uma lei
para dizer que a gente não pode rodar na
empresa o que a gente pode fazer é enfim
das coisas mais mas naturais a ponto de
a gente ficar não terá essa
autodeterminação e quando vi colocar a
mão no estado